KENNY.
>> TACO BELL
>> HAD IT TAKEN AWAY
BY BUCHNEVICH. A
BEAUTIFUL LITTLE
.
WHEN YOU SEE A
GOALTENDER THA
QUICK. HE HAD A MIC BACK
IN THE DAY.
HE HAS ON
THE NET.
THE REBOBO BORTUZZO.N O
STICK.
RIGHT THERERY
BARBASHEV.
MOVERS IS NOW 0-3 ON THE
POWER PLAYWERE OFF
TO THE
HERE'S CLAGUE UP THE
MIDDLE.
[BUZZER]
KENNY: HE SCORES
GETS PAST
BINNINGTON.
EDDIE: DON'T KNOW IF
IT WENT OFF THE
STICK OFT IN FRONT FOR
SHOT BY IAFALLO.
BLOCM
AND PUTS IT RIGHT
>> THAT'S TRUE.F THE
>> CALLED IN
REAL-TIME AND NOT
REVIEWABLE SO PLAY
15 SECONDS.
HERE'S KYROU.
CENTERING PASS,
TALKED ABOUT FROM
REALLY THE FIRST
SHIFT OF THE GAIN
TIES IT IF THEY
COULD GET PUCK
POSSESSIONTES REMAININGN
SUDDEN DEATH
OVERTIME.
TIED 2-2.
>> FIRST OVERTIME
S.
COVERED UP BY
BINNINGTON.
>> REALLY
INTELLIGENT PLAY BY
GOOD POWER MOVE
THOMAS.
FINAL MINUTE OF
OVERTIME
THE HANDLE.
HERE'S
CATCHES THES A M.
>> PRETTY MOVE, VERYIT Y
IAFALLO.>> LET'S SEE IF
PERIOD.
MOVING DOWN THE
RIGHT SIDE.